[Music]
so Michael Jordan you heard of him nope
yes well he was a very famous basketball
player there's a documentary if you
would like to learn about him he put up
some shoes at one point but he has now
conquered a new element not just air but
waters [ __ ] water
are you okay what are you doing horrible
what happened like you just gonna feel a
little tickle in the back here yeah yeah
that's what I had earlier I was eating
cashews though leave Corona no oh oh
today anyway do you want to know about
Michael Jordan like why are you I love
him I'm like his biggest fan
so Michael Jordan caught a big-ass blue
marlin what what the [ __ ] is going on
right now he won three million dollars
Oh fishing tournament he loved he's very
competitive so [ __ ] you want to see how
big this Marlin is it's a treatment yes
what is not good that's [ __ ] up
because it's like I get you're great at
sports like it's not fair we have a
friend that would play for the NBA right
we went to his house and I was trying to
challenge it and ping-pong and he beat
the [ __ ] out of me and then our home was
like if you're naturally that good I
like I like a top sport you're gonna be
good at every sport yeah it destroys you
the confidence to win like what the
winner is just fishing you put it in the
thing like how how about you try to that
Marlin cuz he has a winner's mentality
now do you gotta like bent how he tugged
the shape to and like oh my god that's
some good like - unless the fish was
like this oh [ __ ] Michael Jordan
I'm going to Jordan dude I wonder what
slight little thing that Mama's did that
made Michael Jordan go I'm gonna [ __ ]
catch him alright the tiniest you
haven't watched it yet no I know about
that okay maybe you saw a Marlin in the
ocean with the like little spike through
a Jordan shoe in Eagles [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that's disrespecting me bro
yeah he also did play baseball and he
might have a thing against the Marley
oh he was a better badder than people
give him credit for everyone's like he
sucked at baseball and they even open
space jam with like yo this ain't for
you buddy alright right it was funny but
he was actually pretty decent at it
considering where he was and you go to
major leagues no use in the minors but I
played pro but they said how I only know
this from watching the Dutchman if he
would have kept that if like another
year he probably would have could've got
to the majors yeah cuz he had like a
three of 300 whatever batting average
which is like really [ __ ] good mm-hmm
all right I can't this thing's not
loading but here's the picture how big
this frickin morale holy where's Michael
he's the tallest guitarist and also the
only black guy in the photo so I don't
know looking for the height and the
ankle okay you're looking for the air
jordans maybe it's 440 2.3 pounds
oh they should've just left it in the
ocean well it's dead now so one do one
get three million dollars I think it's
about three a million dollars crazy it's
all him he's just gonna gamble with it
he really loves it so it was three
million because he won the contest
yeah tournament holy [ __ ] it was the
62nd annual big rock blue marlin
tournament he wanted we won the first
place I don't know what inside it had to
join that tournament but it's a
competition he needed well maybe he just
likes fishing cuz I know he likes to
play golf
yeah retired he's like ah I could fish
yeah that's like rich people like
leisure sport - OH
golf an infix come he doesn't want a
golf tournament yeah you probably have
knock but Tom Brady lost had a golf
tournament
ladies him versus Peyton Manning and
Tiger Woods and his hand in like Phil
Mickelson didn't someone get like a home
run Tom Brady did but he sucked though
until then so he wasn't able to make up
for how he sucked with but then he got a
hole-in-one giving everyone likes to say
old Tom Brady is a great finisher but he
couldn't close it couldn't close it
Glenn Close and okay okay close it I
went fishing once you know why why those
fish No oh sorry
[Laughter]
alley-oop and then Nicky comes out and
knocks his own like Dennis Rodman I
watched the documentary I would fish you
once you know why why for the halibut
god dammit dude get the [ __ ] out that
one you like that one better when Nicky
knocked the alley but it's my specialty
I always accidentally ruin tim set up
his own setup he tried to set up a joke
at playlist live on a panel like three
times I know that honest that doesn't
sound like good I was like finally I
spit she's like oh my god it was a joke
I'm always does it to me but then I just
destroy her a little bit emotionally and
then that's true that's very true and
I'm like why were you show me then you
get really good as she starts crying
you're like oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up and then
I really wanted thank you y'all are
heartless all good here's what I don't
get how great is it that you reeled in
this giant fish but you had to use all
these tools what tools what else he
picked up a 600-pound fish you wanted
him to dive down in and pick a fish up
with his hands he picked it up with a
string you could barely see yeah it's a
huge looking lever and all [ __ ]
you've never been fishing the other you
know I know but it's on it's it's it's
little secure to the boat no it's not
yes it is
some of them some are but you think he's
hold the [ __ ] real like that he gets
his sister Michael Jordan of course how
do you do a baby how do you catch it
well I wouldn't want to catch a
long-term way too heavy I would want to
catch like a big catfish well then you
want to win the competition with your
hands well that's what this is a
[ __ ] opportune you're in the middle
ocean you're going from Marlin and he
catches a [ __ ] river catfish I'd be
like in the ocean the biggest river
catfish in the ocean everyone's playing
battleship you're trying to run a
Scrabble it's a sickie 67th annual ocean
river fish catching competition so far
nobody's won but I'm the first winner of
the 67,000 my brain what two is d-tools
do you have just a fishing rod like this
there's a six-foot four hole right here
Oh what six-foot poor tool I'll give you
part of my tool and we'll see we'll see
how it feels it was long it was two
nights ago you're gonna have to
masturbate tonight I probably should and
then I would have lasted longer yeah
maybe you could tackle me later fishing
fun I need to take a [ __ ]
you guys are making me feel like we
should just turn this camera off what
sport do you think you could beat
Michael Jordan at because I think I
could probably operation badminton maybe
badminton is the white people spoiling
would what why do you know what really I
grew up playing Bevin he I think you
honestly Onew so that the game that
Nadine was talking about we were playing
at this guy's house right and so we're
friends with his strength and
conditioning coach so that guy is just
saying when you're a pro at that level
it's just like this half of it is his
god-given hand-eye coordination ability
that he's already seeing [ __ ] in slow
motion before he even learned the sport
anything that he touches he's already
seeing it like break broken down in
zeros and ones while [ __ ] mere
mortals are like here in your Bart but I
would rack his ass at Street Fighter 2
turbo baby he would have no [ __ ]
chance that's what I was gonna say
animal crossing I feel like sports
please guys sports but then all of the
tank Oh J eSports is a thing now bro is
crossing two boards no no but there's a
fishy tournament in Animal Crossing and
I'm just saying I think I could win but
I could beat him at speed walking
yeah but then all we take is from you
guys his legs are pretty low but are you
guys beat him ones and then he would
like train for a [ __ ] year it's
answer his texts anymore after that I'll
never grant him a rematch I'm Mac luck
no Geo's already married to that
personality type I feel like she she
lady got more endurance why was she way
that competitive oh no you're right no
he's not
are you competing to be the least
competitive yeah yes yeah damn I feel
like Michael Jewell I could maybe be him
at Taekwondo hmm I'm not really good
sponge probably a short contest
yeah yeah my horse jockey okay that will
sit on a horse and the horse dies the
bags limbo limbo I could beat him at
holding my breath lower center of
gravity
let's see them all the Reds along is
right now are you ready okay okay ready
go in the beam here I'll go you right
you're holding oh I'm sorry wait Michael
Jordan's not even here I know why are we
competing
okay what do they go no it's good so
anyway I would think yeah my forgiveness
you can take a slim shadey oh hi my name
is but now we gotta come back in we're
gonna keep listening to this [ __ ]
can't come back in here Slim Shady guys
really doing this six mile the song goes
hey not breathing how does it go well
that exhaling I didn't I didn't just
breathe so is it just a cop what are you
doing you're not breathe through your
ears
are you still holding the breath marry
me I'm out man Anna are you similar bet
she knows his move
what about you yeah like if you want to
shut people up they're not gonna work
with kids dude they're smarter now if
the kids shows teach them this thing on
how they [ __ ] with them
ah man and that's one things I've
learned well I won't show me shows sure
don't show the technology yeah keep
playing basketball and then he will
eventually catch the market rock we
don't even have I can't even measure if
you guys are breathing in through your
nose and cheating though what does that
mean and chiotti it's Yeti how's the
phone one had really doing it stupid I
guess squeeze out like ten whiteheads do
that you're still going at it that's all
people it's not fair the airs thinner up
there survivor
what okay they're all right we got to do
this like underwater so it could really
see who was breathing it was not
breathing
I believe her how is super honest it was
pretty competitive [ __ ] yeah I feel like
Michael Jordan won't hold his breath
until you die think he would an exhale
so then I could pass on camera and then
it would be like who has the widest eyes
content conscious his eyes already
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]